ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد في جلسه نقاش
على هامشي منتدى الاقتصاد العالمي داغوث
اشار وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان الى ان المملكه توصلت او تواصلت
مع ايران لمحاوله البحث عن طريق وسبل
للحوار ولمناقشه القضايا الخلفيه وتداوز
الخارجيه السعودي على ان الحوار هو السبيل
الامثل لحل الخلافات والمساء الى الشائكه
بطريقه تضمن عدم المساس بالمصالح الخاصه
والمتعلقه بكل دوله واضاف بان تضفر الجهود
والتعاون والعمل المشترك في المنطقه سيحقق
الازدهار والرخاء لكل شعوب المنطقه في
اشاره ايضا لان الطاقه يعد امرا اساسيا
للغايه بالنسبه للمملكه وان الاستقرار هو
المفتاح المطلق لامن الطلقه
ايران
تواصلنا معهم ونحاول ايجاد سبيل للتحاور
مع جيراننا لاننا نؤمن بشده بان الحوار هو
السبيل الامثل لحل الخلافه
نشعر بقوه بان ما قمنا به في المملكه وما
يقوم به اخرون في المنطقه خاصه دول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي لمعالجه تحديات
الاقتصاداتهم والاستثمار في دولتهم على
التنميه وليس على المسائل الجيو السياسيه
كانت علامه قويه لايران واخرين في المنطقه
لانه هناك مسار بعيدا عن الجدالات
والنزاعات القديمه تجاه الازدهار المشترك
كل ما تمكنا من التعاون في المنطقه كل ما
عملنا معا وحققنا الازدهار ليس فقط لشعبنا
بل لملتقتنا وخارجي»
هناك شهاده الموضوع مع ضيوفي يوسف عزيزي
البحث
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا بكم واسمح لي
ان ابدا من لندن معك سيد يوسف سيد يوسف
معادله اييي الازدهار والتنميه في داخل
الايراني والازدهار بالنسبه لكل الدول
مقابل استمرار الصراعات والنزاعات الحاضره
والتاريخيه هل تلتقط ايران هذه الرساله
تحياتي لكم
واهلي مشاهديكم الكرام
ايران يعني تعرفون ان ال العلاقات بين
الدول
هي تابعه لمتغيرات الدوليه
واقليميه وداخليه
فاذا طبقناها على ايران والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه
نرى الان
المتغيرات الدوليه
ليست لصالح ايران
يعني في الواقع
اليوم اخر
اجراء كان تصويت اييه
البرلمان الاوروبي
لدرس ايران على قائمه درجه الحرس الثوري
على قائمه المنظمات
الاقليمي
ايضا يعني ليست ايران كما هي قبل مثلا
سنوات
بطريقه مختلفه
انا توصل الى الوضع الداخلي الوضع الداخلي
هو كما تسمعون يعني منذ اربعه اشهر
وكل جهد النظام الايراني
لاخماد الثوره المدلعه يعني في الواقع في
عده مدن ايرانيه
فلهذا الصور
ايران ممكن ان
يعني تنوي ان تعيد علاقاتها مع جيرانها
وقاصر العربيه السعوديه
لكن
لحد الان همم
يعني بعدها في الواقع في نوع من التعنت
يعني
المفاوضات النوويه الى طريق مسدود
في العلاقات او
مفاوضات الخاصه باستئناف العلاقات في
بغداد
همم سنه ونصف هو نفس المصير في الموقع
ايران تتعنت ولكن كل شيء وارد وربما هذه
الظروف ستدفعها للتعامل بطريقه مختلفه مع
جيرانها ومن بينهم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه سالتقت منك ليس التردد والتعمد
سالتقت الجانب الايجابي والمتفائل همم سيد
يوسف من قراءتك وانقولها لضيف السيد
الحربي سيد الحربي هل انت همم بينفس هذه
الروح المتفائله تتوافق مع ضيف في هذه
الرؤيه
ريم لو عدنا للحمله الانتخابيه الرئاسيه
الماضيه همم في ايران نجد انه معظم
المترشحين سواء محسن رضائي ابراهيم رئيسي
وغيره كان الحديث الاكثر هو علاقه مع
الرياضه
ويبدو انه هذا شبه اجماع كان بين المرشحين
وهي نقطه بلا شك واحد يتوقف عندها همم
كثيرا لماذا طهران حريصه على العلاقه مع
الرياض في ظني لانه طهران ادرى كانت انه
همم مشروعها في المنطقه استطاعت الرياض
الى حد ما تحجيبه واسقاطه في اليمن بدا
يتحجب نوعا ما في في العراق همم هناك همم
تراجع للمشروع الايراني في لبنان وايضا في
سوريا حتى في سوريا رفعوا سعر النفط على
الدوله السوريه من 30 الى 70$ فهذا اكد طه
انه لا يمكن تجاوز الرياض وانه هناك حاجه
ملحه لاعاده العلاقه مع الرياض لانه
الذاكره الايرانيه تتذكر انه الرياض لعب
الدور في اعاده طهران الى المنطقه اذا
ذكرناها في حقبه رب سنجاني وخاتمي وتم
توقيع الاتفاقيه الامنيه في 2001 هناك بلا
شك حوار بين الرياض وطهران خمس جولات
واعتقد انه الايرانيين همم توقفوا كثيرا
امام خطاب خادم الحرمين الشريفين امام
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده 76 عندما
حدد الركائز الخمسه في العلاقه مع ايران
انه ايران دوله جاره همم عليها الالتزام
بالمواثيق والمعاهده الدوليه احترام
السياده عدم التدخل بالشؤون الداخليه
وايضا ايقاف دعم المنظمات الارهابيه
والمدير الاشياء
الموقف السعودي واضح هو همم لما نراقب
التصريحات او لما نراقب الفعل والقول
المقصود سعودي واضح ولكن ثقف الايراني
حضرتك تتحدث عن تصريحات همم تدعم اهميه
الجيره وتدعم اهميه التعاون في المنطقه
ولكن على مستوى الافعال همم هل نرى شيء
ايجابي في تحركات ايران الاخيره مثلا
المطلوب الان لانه همم تلاحظ الايرانيين
بالعاده بدون في طرح تصريحات ثم بدايه
مشروعه من الذكر 2015 عندما تحدث علي
يونسي عن عوده الامبراطور الايرانيه
وعاصمتها بغداد وحيدر مصلحه عن السيطره
على اربع عواصم عربيه الان هما يتنكرون
لهذا الخطبات ويرون انه ليس خطاب رسمي
الجولات الخمسه انقضاء خمس جولات بين
الرياض وطهران يؤدي الى انه هناك شيء ما
يتحرك بالتاكيد ايران الان ليست ايران
الغربي اعتقد ان المشهد الدولي يوحي في
حراك ما وعلينا ان ان انتظر تنعكس على
الافعال همم مهمه تحول الاشياء هذه
الاقوال او على الاقل ان تتجسد فعلا استاذ
يوسف همم هل يمكن لهذا الحراره الدولي
لهذه التصريحات ان تبني شيئا فعليا ضيف
يقول بان هناك تصريحات يمكن تاسيس عليها
ولكن هل تمر طهران من مرحله الاقوال الى
مرحله الفعل
انا
اصحح انا لست متفائلا
زال العلاقات الايرانيه السعوديه لان هناك
عده في الواقع الحواجز تمنع هذه تحسين هذه
العلاقات فانظروا مثلا خلال العام الماضي
20 22 لم يتم لم تتم ايه مفاوضات الا مره
واحده همم
والان ايضا هي متوقفه
رغم ان يبدو ااه السيد
السوداني او عزالي وزير الخارجيه
التحرك لاستئناف هذه المفاوضات لكن همم
فقط
في موضوعنا الثالث عن العراق سنه سنتابع
لانه المواضيع مترابطه تفضل سيد يوسف اكمل
لان كمان ذكرت انا يعني لما
الانتفاضه المستمره منذ اربعه اشهر في
الواقع اثرت على استمرار هذه هي المفاوضات
يعني في الواقع الايرانيين الان
الايرانيون الان يتهمون السعوديه بالتدخل
في هذه الاحتجاجات والمظاهرات واا نعرف ان
همم خاصه ان وزير خارجيه همم ايران ان لم
يذكر اسم السعوديه لكن ذكر اسم همم قناه
ايران
انترناشونال اللي تتهم ايران بان العربي
السعوديه تدعمه بالضبط السعوديه تنفيذ ذلك
فهذا انا اتصور مطروح همم فيها في اي
مفاوضات
مقبل حتى الان بدون مفاوضات هو مطروح في
الكلام اللي همم يتم همم
الجهازين الدبلوماسيين فهذا امر مهم فئران
تسر على همم ايقاف هذا القناه اللي همم
رغم همم يعني بعض الملاحظات الموجوده عليك
بالضبط السعوديه تنفي انها تدعم ذلك فهذه
وضحت الفكره
على طاوله كما تحدثت عن الحراره الدولي
همم اليوم سيد الحربي ايران تشكو من ازمه
اقتصاديه خانقه ادت الى احتجاجات متعاقبات
هل هذه الاسماء الاقتصاديه مع الحراك
السياسي الدولي مع عرض السعوديه بامكانيه
ان تكون هناك مشاركه بيننا لكل الاطراف قد
تفعل شيئا ايجابيا باختصار لو سمحت
من 2004 تقريبا 300 مليار على مليار دولار
على مشروعات لم تعد تملك القدره على
استمرار هذه الممارسه الى شك انه هذا يلعب
دور ولكن خلنا نشيل انا اعتقد انه في
مؤشرين مهمين حتى نعرف هل ايران تحولت من
الاقوال الى افعال الاول في موضوع
الحوثيين ودعم الحوثيين الموضوع الثاني في
لبنان وموضوع الرياسه اللبنانيه هذه
مؤشرين مهمين يعطونا دلالات حل ايران بدات
تتراجع الى حد ما عن ممارستها
الحربيه الكاتب المحلل السياسي ومن لندن
يوسف عزيزي الباحه الايراني شكرا لكم